[Music]
tell us about the new daytime show you
had Martha Stewart appear on the program
because you've taped some of these
already yeah well we did a pilot and one
of the segments that we're doing is
called stall talk and I'm in one stall
of a bathroom and my guess is in the
next stall and you interview them wait
where the dirty show you're actually
you're interviewing people in the back
I'm not really doing they're sitting the
seats down and they're so weird is this
an interview it's a it's a different way
of doing an interview yes it certainly
is
I can think of other interesting ways to
do an interview was cute and bar and she
um Martha you got Martha Stewart - she
loves to play
her name was up in a lot of the
bathrooms - I noticed with the numbers
so but like I said no it wasn't she
really isn't that way she talked about
the bathroom etiquette she at one point
handed me a cake underneath the stall
because I was having a party that
weekend when I had when I said cake I
can't wait to say hey it's been on a
bathroom floor it's on a cake plate and
it's not on the floor
oh then yummy yummy and and it's very
and she handed me a square in the shape
of a origami swan it was wonderful but
laughing was the Swan going is this
gonna be a recurrence is this gonna be a
recurring theme a lot of people you
would be great doing stall talk you
would be fabulous wouldn't he be great
in a bath
don't know why I'd be particularly
better there than everyone seems to
think yes I much I would far prefer to
see him in that venue now at first is
this true you wanted to do your new show
when you decide to do a daytime show you
to set you you wanted to do it in your
own home I did but my husband said no
that that was ridiculous because I
didn't really want to get dressed and
all that stuff so I mean I obviously had
PJs but you know I didn't want to yo go
into the office right so that was nixed
but what they did is they recreated our
family room it's almost an exact
duplicate and then I brought in our real
furniture which has been destroyed by
our animals it's torn to bits it's
disgusting so you've recreated your
disgusting yes I have and it's great by
the way this is exactly what my house
looks like I live down by the water near
the giant moon it's real it's authentic
yeah it's very nice yeah and it starts
on September 8th it starts on September
8th yes okay and is it gonna be every
day of four days a week five days a week
well five days a week yeah okay that's
great yeah at least in the beginning
yeah that's good yeah yeah that's good
that's my dog was gonna be on a Jasper
who some people may know cuz he was on
The Today Show occasionally but he's
very protective of me and he would if
you came in and I hugged you he would
probably bite your testicles very
protect let me get this straight if I
come on your show I get to eat cake
that's been on the bathroom floor and a
dog chomps my testicle
there I am so on
my favorite thing Meredith Vieira show
premieres on September 8 and this Friday
at 8 p.m. NBC is going to air a leap of
faith a Meredith Vieira that's about
regenerative medicine which is literally
the growing of organs and it's not
science fiction anymore in the lab so if
Jasper did eagerly guided us away from
if he did you could grow a new pair
I could just see me waiting for the
FedEx package Oh bring that thing in
here beep-beep
you